[Music]
have you ever heard
the phrases the results were significant
early
i guess i can call it now or
my boss is getting really antsy i think
she wants to test results soon
they seem directionally positive or
we really need to balance statistical
rigor with the needs of the business
the same flurry of phrases would always
overwhelm the data scientists in my
meetings
bad fluorescent overhead lighting
illuminating the battleground
between statistical rigor and the
omnipresent
needs of the business as a former data
scientist
turned product manager and self-declared
data nerd i see both sides of the story
i wanted to help bridge the gap between
my business and data peers
by understanding experimental methods
that allow organization
to run tests more quickly and maintain
statistical rigor today i'll walk you
through three easy-to-follow steps
motivated by my own experiences at
intuit
so that you can apply it to your own use
cases for running experiments
more quickly and statistically
rigorously
first we'll talk about how to take big
swings so you can learn
and fail quickly
two we'll talk about what sequential
testing is
and how to use it so that you can end
test early
confidently and three we'll talk about
how to use r
so that i and you can share your
learnings
with your organization even non-data
scientists
in reality businesses do need to move
quickly to stay innovative
however the results of reading a test
early could be catastrophic
leading to your business decision being
no better than a coin flip
here is data for simulated aa test a
test where we have two cohorts
but they have exactly the same
experience we know
that since these two experiences are
exactly the same
there should be no statistically
significant difference
between the two however
as you can see over a 30-day window the
p-value
actually crosses the significance
threshold a number of times
all due to random chance
if you were to call your test early you
could be reading
the same noise and instead of making an
informed
data-backed business decision you could
simply
be rendering your business decision no
better than if you had flipped a coin
the first big experiment i ever ran i
fell prey to this exact fallacy
we were testing a new version of a
recommendation model
and we wanted to test our recommendation
model out in the wild against an older
iteration
this was the perfect candidate for an a
b test
however to move our baseline metric of
three percent we needed almost a million
samples
and it would take us three months to run
guess what no surprise we cheated
for the recommendation experiment we
used
three-day connection rate as i braceline
metric this suffered from being a bottom
of the funnel metric
because not only did the users have to
see the recommendation and click on it
then they had to connect and also hold
on to that connection for at least three
days
for us to register that as a win that
led to our metric
being only 2.88 percent which is fairly
low to make matters worse we are taking
only a tiny swing
only aiming to move our baseline metric
by three percent
with such a low mineral detectable
effect of three percent
we needed 12 weeks or three months to be
able to fully bake our test
if you think about it we're looking to
move a baseline metric of 2.88
by only three percent which led to an
absolute would have led to an absolute
lift
of less than a tenth of a percent if we
had taken a bigger swing
of 10 percent 7.5 percent
or even just 5 as our minimum detectable
effect
we could have reduced our test time from
the 12 weeks we needed
to just two weeks a year later we ran a
second experiment
where we wanted to learn from our
missteps from our first experiment
in this second experiment we wanted to
test automating sales tax
we wanted to show users country specific
sales tax rate
for their region in their first time use
experience
and this time we wanted to apply the
principle of taking big swings
to our test this time we used a metric
much closer to the user
action engagement clicks with a
relatively high baseline of about seven
percent
more importantly we declared that we
were going to take a
big swing and said our minimum
detectable effect had to be a hundred
percent
meaning that our baseline conversion
rate of seven percent
had to double to fourteen percent
this time we were able to take our
projected timeline
to be only two weeks the key idea
taking big swings to learn and fail
quickly
is one of the biggest levers you can
push to speed up
your experience but we wanted to do even
better
by taking our experimental philosophy of
taking big swings
we were able to layer on an av testing
enhancement
sequential testing which allowed us to
take our two-week test time and actually
cut it in half
to just one week but what is sequential
testing
sequential testing is kind of like doing
your taxes it allows you
to not overspend and waste time
um waiting for results when you could
have already called it but it also
ensures that you don't
under spend time and actually call a
test that's not statistically regressed
sequential testing allows you to take
that spend that exact right amount of
time
such that when you call the test you
didn't overspend or under spend time
to be able to call a winner the way that
it does that
is by building in a checkpoint or
multiple checkpoints
where you can check the results of your
test and peak
earlier than a standard fixed horizon
test
sequential testing is also ideal for
software
situations because software gives us the
unique ability to monitor results in
real time which means at any moment of a
peak
we can go ahead and analyze the results
in that moment
additionally since we have their
experimental philosophy of taking big
swings
it really lends itself to sequential
testing because
sequential testing has the unique
ability to call winners
early for our sales tax test we applied
two checkpoints
one at the 50 mark where half the
numbers half of the total samples had
come in
and one at the 100 percent mark where a
total
our full sample set had come in at
approximately two weeks
at each checkpoint you can see that we
have a z-score acceptance criteria
necessary to be able to successfully
determine a winner
the acceptance criteria are much more
stringent in the earlier checkpoints
to account for the smaller sample size
that you're using to determine whether
there's a winner
note that the z-score acceptance
criteria is greater than the 1.96
critical value which we normally see
during fixed horizon testing
it's there because we're paying a small
price to be able to peak
earlier namely the prices that our
experiments is slightly less powerful
in a statistical sense so that we may
miss the detection of a true effect
or win in this case we're using
something called the o'brien fleming
boundary which we've chosen because it
tries to minimize that payment
at the end of the test because we're
trying to get as close to the 1.96
critical value as we can
with that last peak as an aside if you
want to check out more there's many more
boundaries you can use which may suit
your needs
more i wanted to make building a
sequential test plan
as simple as possible to abstract away
the statistical complexities so that
anyone in my company
could use it to do that i designed and
built an rflex dashboard
to make creating a test plan as simple
as filling out
just a few data points here you can see
my flex dashboard for my sales tax test
pre-filled we included the baseline
conversion rate
of our primary metric 7.03
the power we wanted or 80 here which is
an industry standard
a statistical significance level of five
percent which is also
an industry standard and here
we included our big swing requirement of
a hundred percent
and finally we included the optional
value of our weekly traffic
to help translate our sample size
requirement to the amount of time we
would need
until this point these are all values
you would include
in a normal a b test plan sample size
calculation
the only additional value we needed to
include was the number of peaks
we wanted to take during our test since
our normal a b test
already had an estimated time of two
weeks we only wanted to add
one checkpoint to be able to account for
normal weekly behavioral fluctuations
therefore here we include the number of
peaks to be just
two
at the top we have three key numbers
available
number of peaks or two in this case that
we've set
the total number of samples that we
would need
and finally the total amount of time it
would take given the number of samples
on our average weekly traffic
both of these numbers are based on a
normal a b testing sample calculation
sample size calculation
here our table shows us the breakdown of
samples needed
number of days and then the lower and
upper
z-score thresholds for each checkpoint
given all of our inputted values
finally our threshold graph illustrates
our z-score threshold changes
with each checkpoint ultimately
being able to use this dashboard and
share out my test plan
i was able to go from an earlier test
with 1 million samples to only needing
samples and taking half the time of a
normal fixed rise in a b test
and instead of taking three months to
bake we only needed to wait
one week and instead of needing the full
bake time
we were able to have multiple
checkpoints to really get
the right amount of time to be able to
guarantee statistical rigor without
wasting
any time and finally the most important
of all
remove the temptation to cut corners and
instead we're able to guarantee
statistically rigorous results at
shorter time points
so how do we get there as a reminder
there are
three simple steps you need to take to
be able to
achieve these goals for yourself one
remember to take big swings don't take a
minimum detectable effect that's too
small that's a huge lever to be able to
make your experiment shorter
right off the bat two use sequential
testing
now that you know how it can be simple
to just implement an overlay on top of
your own a b
tests and three
using our shiny flex dashboard or
you know your own tool of choice to be
able to demonstrate
how to do this to everyone in your
organization and share the goodness that
is sequential testing
so that everyone even non-data
scientists
can run shorter more statistically
rigorous tests now with just those three
tips and tricks in your tool belt
you can avoid early significant results
disappointing your ansi boss and
business constraints
because now you have all the tools you
need to be able
to run your tests shorter
and reliably so that everyone in
organization
can feel confident in your results
[Music]
you